il y a à ce propos beaucoup de
désinformation qui circule actuellement
sur les réseaux sociaux sur internet
énormément céline en fait rappelez vous
du fameux slogan là le poids des mots le
choc des photos le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on va prendre des photos
et on va complètement réinventé
l'histoire qu'on va changer complètement
le contexte quelques exemples bien
justement on a beaucoup vu circuler
cette photo ce montage photographique
regardez c'est forcément un djihadiste
il est armé jusqu'aux dents il est dans
le désert et là mon dieu on l'a retrouvé
il se trouve déjà en allemagne
en fait ça c'est une image qui a
beaucoup a été partagé lorsque justement
l'état islamique prétendait avoir réussi
à infiltrer par milliers ces fameux
bateau de migrants mais quand on fait
une petite vérification
en fait ce personnage que certains ont
retrouvé était en fait un commandant de
l'armée syrienne libre donc il a
combattu
l'état islamique un autre exemple aussi
assez intéressant de ce genre de
manipulation vont regarder ici ce sont
forcément des djihadistes qui sont
bâties là comme des bodybuilders ils
vont arriver ils vont égorger nos filles
et nos enfants
en fait pas du tout c'est une photo qui
date de 2013 et c'est au large des côtes
australiennes donc ça n'a rien à voir
cette image si ici mais regardez ils
étaient armés jusqu'aux dents ça y est
arrivé déjà par train en europe donc
forcément ça va être un djihadiste or il
n'est même pas barbu en fait c'est
quelqu'un c'est un kurde qui a justement
combattu le fameux état islamique donc
l'idée c'est toujours faire peur en
montrant des images chocs
regardez celle ci encore qu'ils aient
beaucoup diffusé sur les réseaux
d'extrême droite et les partis
xénophobes en fait ça date de 91 ce sont
des albanais qui tentait de quitter pour
l'italie donc on change complètement
l'histoire finalement bon il ya même
l'image du petit alan corde il quiconque
on accuse d'être truquée d'avoir été
falsifiés en fait sur les laisse pas
parce qu'on appelle les complotistes les
fameux complotistes donc forcément c'est
de la manipulation regarder en fait le
petit alan était trouvé ici et donc
c'est le gendarme turc il a bougé pour
que ce soit un peu plus dramatiquement
fait pas du tout c'est pas le même
enfant en fait c'était son frère qui lui
aussi est mort donc le petit galli donc
on le voit on il n'y a pas de limite à
la désinformation
et est ce que c'est possible de faire la
différence entre le vrai du faux
c'est très difficile parce que le
problème c'est que outre laissé
d'extrême droite qui est vraiment
diffusés à grande échelle ce genre
d'imagés aussi des sites humoristiques
qui se paye un peu la traite en
diffusant aussi d
voir qu'ils n'ont vraiment aucun sens
par exemple ici le premier ministre
français qui offrent mille maisons aux
migrants en france
le canada qui va forcer les futurs
immigrants à boire de l'alcool et
consommer du porc parce qu'on veut rien
savoir forcément des musulmans selon la
rumeur mais en fait c'est que c'est
difficile évidemment de faire la
vérification alors à côté de ça
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on peut
peut-être regarder d'où via l'image en
fait d'où vient la photo il ya une
petite fonction que sur google images
vous tapez l'adresse de la photo et vous
allez capable de remonter un peu la
source pour savoir exactement c'était
quoi le contexte de cette photo oui
peut-être les médias traditionnels
parfois ça peut aider
ça peut aider oui merci vous couvrirez
quel prix